is just unbearable like it's crap bad
quality bad writing Disney held
children's attention for a while they
were good stewards of that attention
like a lot of the entertainment industry
they become captured by ideology and
ideology makes for boring stories you
always have to kind of look twice at
what your kid is reading you know it's
so incipit there's people just trying to
get into your child's
mind sadly Disney was just dropping
these fairy tales with them they were
like we don't want these we you know we
actually don't like them anymore and so
I thought this would be a great time to
do
this Jonathan P welcome to my podcast
it's great to see you again Michaela how
much do you think um social media has to
play in the last decade of weirdness
like I feel like in
2012 there were there were some like I
was in university and you could kind of
see some of the woke stuff coming into
play but because there wasn't such a
strong online social media following for
these things they didn't blow up as fast
do you think that's why we're seeing
such ups and downs and like chaos and
politics and things cuz like everybody
can suddenly get kind of a one certain
idea and one way of thinking and they're
just spammed with that information
that's right I think that's the right
way to see it is that you know in a
normal in a normal like let's say just
30 years ago or 20 years ago you could
watch the news and be funnel into a
certain idea you know or you could even
be manipulated I mean it's not like
propaganda is a new thing it's something
that's existed for a very long time and
so you could get kind of dragged into
propaganda but then you know that would
last a certain amount of time and you
would move away from that and then you
would encounter other people and you
would live your life and there'd be a
kind of organic reality where you're
constantly surrounded by people that
have different opinions different ideas
different things that they value but now
what happens with the online world is
that in some ways again like what I said
before is you can fall into one thread
and then you can have massive
reinforcement in that thread it you know
you can find yourself surrounded by
people online you can find yourself
surrounded by people who only agree with
you and are completely in line with this
one thing that you are aiming towards so
that's true for as it's as true for kind
of weird F fetishistic thing or little
people who get obsessed by certain
cultural you know cultural uh let's say
cultural niches but it's then it also
becomes true for political ideas as well
where people just get dragged into
something and it's people have become
way easier to manipulate now with social
media for sure how do you specifically
avoid being manipulated by social media
like do you ever find yourself thinking
one way a little too strongly and you're
like maybe I need to see the other side
or do you use like a moral compass how
do you figure it out I probably am
manipulated sometimes you know that is
I'm not I wouldn't be surprised if that
happened what I hope is that in some
ways similar to some of the things that
your father has developed that if you
have a sense of how reality has a left
and a right hand you could say and how
you know every movement in One Direction
hides something you know a kind of
ignorance of another movement in another
Direction I think I I kind of have an
internal clock where when I see things
going too far when I see things getting
pushed my mind immediately reverts to
asking you know a question from the
other perspective and that is you know
on the one hand it is definitely I think
something valuable it can sometimes work
against you because people will accuse
you of not taking strong positions on
certain things that they think are
important and because that I tend to do
that that I always tend to look at a
story and then try to embody it within
the story the different characters and
see things from different perspectives
it means that you know I often don't uh
I don't take a strong positions that as
others have you know in certain even
political situations yeah I can see that
sometimes you actually need people who
just see One Direction like that's
that's something that's very useful
sometimes because you know when critical
problems arise you have to be able to
filter out the other position and you
have to just be able like you know if
you're being robbed on the street you
you that's not the time to ask yourself
you know if you can understand the world
to the position of the person robbing
you you kind of have to react very
quickly uh so so I think that that there
is value in be in not being able to do
that but myself I tend to do that all
the time yeah I think I tend to do that
as well um which and I think I get that
wrong sometimes by seeing the other
side's position a little bit too well
being like well I can see how they got
there and like it doesn't sometimes it
doesn't really matter how they got there
or what the reasons are behind it if the
place you end up is not a good place
Happy Thanksgiving forget my grally
voice voice I'm getting over the plague
given to me by I think my brother uh but
I'm surviving and I want to make money
so I'm here reading ads I hope your
Thanksgiving was amazing if you are
feeling the hangover from Thanksgiving
or if you're preparing for the holidays
we're having a massive sale for
Afterparty The Hangover supplement I
made it's 25% off from Black Friday
which is today to Monday at midnight
this is great for stocking stuffers or
gifts to prepare for New Year's and
Christmas and the holidays I'm not going
to do another 25% off again because then
my margins go so far down it hurts me so
25% off after party it also applies to
subscription orders so you can save more
there you can also use it if you've
bought them already and just love them
like I do Fuller health.com code BF it's
like Black Friday 25 for 25% off linked
in the comments there's a money back
guarantee so you can give a shot with no
worries on ref funds it's so annoying
when companies are annoying so we're
trying to not be annoying highly
recommend giving these a shot even if
you only have the occasional drink to
help save your brain from the effects of
alcohol I hope your Thanksgiving was
wonderful mine was my parents are
staying with us so that's been fun enjoy
the rest of this
episode yeah ideally that would be the
best would be the best would be to be
able to play it out and once you played
it out is to say I can I think I can see
all the positions of this and now I
think this is the morally Superior this
is the best position to to hold I I mean
I think that during during the co stuff
you know at some point I I could
understand how people got caught up in
the narrative and got caught up in the
story and just got but at some point I
was like no like this is you know it's
like when the truckers came out I'm like
I'm sorry I'm going to Ottawa you know
it's like I I just I just have to take a
position even though it's not popular
and even though I can understand why
others are still in this in this kind of
mind Circle uh but I had to take a
position at that point Point did you
actually go so you were there you saw
the protests yeah I didn't know that it
was really it was great and it it just
reinforced my vision that the media is
absolutely corrupt in every way you know
this is something that actually started
with me with Jordan with your father it
was the first time in 2016 that I was
faced with you know The Narrative of
someone I knew and that I talked to and
that I exchanged with and that I had a
sense of and then seeing what the media
were saying at the same time and
thinking they're the they're lying like
they're just lying they're just not
telling the truth uh and then since then
I've become more and more suspicious and
of course you know during Co it just
became insane and when I was at when I
was at the trucker protest you know I
mean it was a protest obviously it was a
protest but it's it's funny that the
media portrayed it so in such a crazy
Vision when just a few years before at
the beginning of covid we literally had
cities burning in the United States
people breaking down things you know
during the George Floyd protest and now
we had this this protest where maybe a
few things went wrong maybe a few people
exaggerated but the media were were were
showing them as basically a bunch of
psychon nais which was hilarious because
that's not what was there yeah yeah wild
uh I was I was I mean I haven't trusted
the media I think I think my mind
changed too when I started seeing like
Dad portrayed as a really evil person I
was like whoa that's yeah that's not
even a Twist on reality that's just
falsehood which which is scary but um I
think all the media institutions are
going to fade away into Oblivion anyway
unless they adapt which they don't seem
to be so they're probably old news yeah
they seem to have taken try to take on
like you know you watch these news
institutions try to take on your freedom
ofies just a detail just a blip it's
like oh this little comedian doing a
podcast it's just hilarious that they're
so blind to what's actually happening
yeah um okay so I will I watched some
clips from the recent debate it was the
Republican
debate and I don't know how up to dat
you are on American politics are you at
all I did not watch I just watched I
just watched the popular ones that were
circulating around Instagram I didn't
actually watch the debate but I've I've
seen quite a bit of what um uh RF K is
talking about and he seems to be the
person that's like in the middle which
is probably how
I've what my political stance is more
than conservative or liberal and so I
was watching a clip he did saying you
know the left has gone too far the right
has gone too far and you know they're
it's just part of the same monster with
two heads and they're fighting each
other and it's going to lead to the
downfall of the us if we don't end up
somewhere in the middle uh and then so I
was like yeah I could stand behind that
but
then do you think because of the
situation we're in in the US and in
Canada there needs to be more push back
from the right to counteract what's
happening with the left or do you think
it's possible for somebody to come up in
the middle and say hey you guys are both
part of the problem let's try and go
forward in the
middle
yeah I I don't want to be a doomsayer
but I think it's I think it's too late
you know at some point it's like there's
when the pendulum starts to
swing at some point you could say well I
wish it was just stable but it's coming
at you and so it's difficult because on
the one hand one side is pushing really
hard for things that have become totally
crazy you know and you know when we talk
about the whole problem of you know of
of mutilating children with the with the
whole transgender question you know at
some point you think well you know we
have to we have to push back you know
just for the sake of the the life of
these these people but then on the other
side they really feel like they're
saving lives when they're doing it so
you have this you have this pendulum
that's swinging and these things that
are kind of going at full force at each
other and it's difficult to compromise
you know it's very difficult to
compromise
so I don't I can't see in the short term
how it's going to settle I think that
there's a desire
possibly and this is sad and tragic to
pull the attention away from this into
something exterior like a war let's say
because that does it like if you have a
war then you bring people together um
but that is also a very sad State of
Affair so I I don't see a good way out
of this and and I do feel like that's
what's happening is that you know that
there's a desire for war so that we can
find some kind of median and so or at
least some kind of common purpose that
will prevent us from just ripping each
other
apart that's interesting I I haven't
considered that that seems right though
because it is I guess when there's
something as terrible as War then people
come together and go okay although the
current War you know the most recent not
it's dividing it's dividing everybody
it's insane I've never seen anything
like it's
not yeah it's not uh it's not it's not
going to work you know there was this
idea that we could all get behind
Ukraine and if we could just all get
behind Ukraine uh then we'll be United
there's also you know that's one of the
reasons for the environmental
apocalypticism is also this you know
it's like I think a lot of it
is a lot of it is anti-human and
ridiculous but you can kind of
understand the drive behind it because
people say well if we could just all
agree that we have to save the Earth
then maybe we could just get along you
know like this this we could come
together as a globe you know you hear
globalists say things like that that you
know this is ways to come together as a
globe we I recently heard from a a WF
panel where the the a woman was talking
about how the next Crisis will or maybe
should be about water because we can all
agree on water right if like there was a
Water Crisis then we would all then we
would all come together and then we
would you know we would come together as
a globe uh and you know even if you want
to push it even stranger in stranger
directions uh do you know do have you
ever heard of Watchmen the graphic novel
Watchmen that came out in the 1980s well
that in that no graphic novel is a great
idea which was if you could fake an uh
extraterrestrial attack then you would
all come together you know and so it's
like you just need something outside of
you that is like a common point of
attention that that joins you together
and you know and in some ways you know
that is in some ways what hopefully
people worshiping God should be doing
right that's what that should be for is
the idea that there's something Beyond
you that is able to capture your
attention and that is able to to be
something that we can all have in common
sadly it has not always played that role
as we know but that is ultimately what
that should be for yeah I I agree how do
you go to people so I I only started
believing in
God maybe two years ago and we had a
conversation since then uh and before
that I couldn't wrap my head around it I
didn't understand what it was and I
didn't understand what people meant when
they said they believed in God was like
I don't even know what that means have
you found a way to talk to people who
are like a agnostic or atheist might be
even too far but like agnostic who are
trying to grasp the concept of God have
you figured out how to kind of explain
what you see I I don't know if i' yeah I
don't know if I've figured it out I
think it's true that a lot of the work
that I've been doing especially on
YouTube or you know the podcast has been
with that goal is to help to bridge the
gap and to help people understand not
just secular atheist people but even
some people who kind of believe in God
sometimes they they do so with a with a
normal kind of naive but not a naive but
something like a very simple intuition
you know and
and because of that sometimes because
they they do it with a simple intuition
when they try to explain it to other
people they they end up sounding
ridiculous like they end up saying
things that would would that that freak
people out and so you know one of the
hopes that I've had is that some of the
things that I say are able to help
people who believe with that kind of
simple intuition formulate it better and
help atheists also understand what it is
that's going on uh and there are
different ways to do it you know for
examp example I just did this speech at
ARC about the idea of
the of of good of the good right in the
platonic sense like of the capital G
good and the idea that you know we have
to have something which transcends our
desires and the transcends all the
things that we think are good you know
like we have things that we think are
good you know like safety or family
or you know our success or there's all
these things that we think are good and
you know usually that's fine but as soon
as we treat any of those things as the
very highest good then all of a sudden
it becomes something like a like a
tyrant over us you know and that's
obviously what someone who becomes I
don't know becomes an alcoholic is it's
like yeah you can drink with friends and
it's Pleasant and it's fun but if all of
a sudden you start to submit your whole
world to that feeling that you get when
you're drinking then something which is
fine like which is a good becomes a
tyrant over you that starts to rule over
you and you know that can happen for
food it can happen for sex it can happen
for anything like anything even things
that we find virtuous like like success
or whatever and so you know I Tred to
help people say like that's the idea one
of the ideas that that religious people
have is that the good is ineffable right
the good is something which is beyond
everything you can imagine and what that
does is it's like just don't think that
whatever you're aiming at now is it
because you can always know that it's
it's it has to be embedded in something
else even if you don't know what that is
even if you can't identify it even if
you don't go you know if you don't you
know believe that God exist it doesn't
matter as long as you cannot hold on to
something and think like you know if I
could just have that then everything
will be settled and you know that's not
true because once you get it you know
either it kind of rules over you because
you have to you have to keep feeding it
or or it disappoints you and then you
fall into despair yeah it's also the
chase I think that gives people more you
know dopamine for lack of a better word
than actually getting to the goal just
chasing right but that's why the idea of
ineffable good like the idea that if you
could like because people would think
that if I could just get that like you
have you meet people like that all the
time it's like I'm like that the worst
thing that could H yeah oh yeah well the
worst thing that could happen is that
you get it right it's like if you think
that your life will be solved once you
get a million dollars then yeah let's
talk when you get that because you're
gonna you're probably going to be pretty
depressed because it's not going to
solve your problems you'll still be the
same person everything you know it won't
change anything just increase actually
your uh possibly increase the problems
that you had in the outset you know and
so uh and so this idea that at least you
know like that whatever it is that you
desire that you're going after is not
the highest thing that you always have
to balance it out with other goods and
that you have to aim it towards higher
and higher Goods ultimately you know
that's love that's good that's true
that's beautiful this is what the West
has identified as what they call what we
call the
transcendentals uh
and that that if we can kind of aim
ourselves that way then then then things
will get better and and I'm hoping that
people atheist and agnostic can kind of
understand now why you need this
ineffable thing at the top right you
need something which transcends
everything that you can understand
transcends everything that you can grasp
or that you can control maybe even is a
good way to say like you can't control
the infinite you know so how how do you
describe that other than the good is
there do you use words like truth and
love like yeah is that what people
should be aiming for as opposed to and
then how do you separate the difference
between goal setting which is important
but making sure that you still have this
aim towards Truth and Love and good at
the top okay because goal setting is
great trying to achieve things that that
aim vaguely upward but you don't well
that's that would be the case the case
is that you if you make sure that your
goal setting is is aimed upward then
that will you know that will help like
if your if your goal is to buy a
Lamborghini then that's not going to do
much for you like I'm sorry to say you
will get it maybe you'll get it but then
what is it going to do but if if your
goal is to accomplish something you know
for example to you know to to be able to
your family have cohesion right to to to
have loving relationships with others to
be able to help those that you see that
are in need and that you know you know
that you have to have a certain amount
of success or if you want to spread a
message that you think is powerful and
meaningful and can help others all these
goals can be something like you said
that can give you that dopamine like can
give you that energy to to keep going
but then what will happen hopefully is
that there's never there's never uh
first of all you never reach it right
it's like if the idea for example having
a loving relationship with your friends
or with your family it's like that's a
goal but it's not a goal that has an end
point it's like a It's actually an
infinite goal it's something that
recedes as you move towards it and you
kind of love that because it's know you
can always be surprised by people and
kind of be simulated and that ultimately
is the idea of you know of a
relationship with God is that God pulls
you into higher and higher states of
virtue you know states of Peace you know
all of these things these are the goals
we should we should want and material
goals are they're fine but they they
won't bring you what you what you think
sometimes yeah so going after success
for material Goods is probably a
hedonistic way of living and probably
not going to get you where you want but
going after success so that you can do
something that benefits people as a
whole that's a different form of success
yeah and also I mean if you for example
if you understand that you want to be an
example for your children you want to be
an example for people around you and you
so you want to be disciplined you want
to to to to do things right uh you know
all of these things are are definitely
good they they're all good things and
even like you said like if you want to
succeeding in business all these things
can be great just as long as they're
embedded in higher things if if they're
just for their own sake then then then
you'll then you'll just be disappointed
you know because they don't have enough
to to you know it's it's as it's it's
very you people can understand it like
in lower terms like if you if your
entire goal in life is eating is eating
is eating good food then you'll always
be empty because it's not enough to
sustain you as a human being it's enough
to maybe sustain the machine but you
you'll find yourself lacking and and and
always either trying to increase your
you know your pleasure like trying to
find more and more rare more and more
subtle things to enjoy but at some point
that runs out and you you you become
yeah you'll just you'll find yourself in
a sad
position how did you introduce these
Concepts to your kids have you been
talking about these kind of pursuing
higher Goods since they were little yeah
but I mean it if you raise ra your
kids I think if you raise your kids in a
Christian vision and with with Christian
values if and if you do that
understanding that it's not just about
some sectarian theological thing that
you have to believe but it's really a
way of living then then ultimately I
think those things will kind of set
themselves into your kids uh on on their
own you know for example like a simple
thing is something like that truth is
important right just that because truth
if you say truth is more important than
your immediate
needs so it's not justified to lie to
get what you want it's not justified to
trick others or to you know to to act in
this in a dishonest way then you're
already setting your kids on the on the
right path just just even that is is a
lot so that they so that they see but
obviously saying it is one thing that
doesn't do much but living it that's the
way to go because your kids they watch
you they don't listen to you yeah they
really well they listen they listen too
but they mostly watch and they'll
they'll so the best thing you can do as
a parent is actually embody the things
you believe are are the best rather than
just teach
them I think when I my my dad obviously
like was very big on that like tell the
truth there's nothing worse than lying
whatever lie you come up with is just
going to bite you in the future and it
turns your life into hell like he was
but um I didn't really understand the
impact of lying when I was little
because sometimes I get in trouble for
doing something and then it was easier
at the time to lie to not get in trouble
yeah and so uh Scarlet recently she did
something she wasn't even going to get
in trouble like she I don't she doesn't
really get in trouble um she's she's a
pretty easy kid but she and I could tell
she was lying she just lied about
something small because she thought I
was going to be mad and I had to
explain that's you that's still not an
excuse to lie but um I've also decided
for like a parenting style that I don't
get mad really um and maybe it's because
she's little she's six and so maybe you
don't get mad at like kids under six
because they're children and I don't
know if anger is the right emotion for a
little kid yeah it's more like why did
you do that what exactly is going on and
why are you acting that way not like
anger um but what what do you think
about that uh that
reaction like is there a is there a time
and place for like anger for kids CU I
do feel like if you have an angry parent
then they end up lying to not get
punished which is like you don't want to
teach a kid that that's the way to get
away with things hey guys just popping
in to remind you of air purifiers you
obviously know I talk about how
important diet is but your environment's
also extremely important and if it's not
taken care of it can override your diet
and exercise results AER Oasis is the
air purifier I use and they're having
the biggest sale I've seen up to 50% off
their products including I adapt air I
bought some for scarlet school not on
sale before they started sponsoring me
and I have them all over my house
they've made the most powerful air
purifiers I've seen that have a medical
grade h13 HEPA filter that filters down
to
0.003 microns which means they trap
particles 10 times smaller than most
other brands this is really important
you can't just get any old air purifier
turns out they have germicidal UV
technology to sterilize the air purifier
itself and the environment they also use
a silver ion filter that penetrates the
cell membrane of mold bacteria and
viruses it reduces pathogens by up to
99% in your air they have three sizes to
choose from with the largest working at
850 Square ft I own a number of them
they're also super quiet they come with
free shipping a lifetime warranty and a
60-day money back guarantee so you can
get up to to 50% off your purchase by
visiting AO oasis.com but if you press
my link linked in the comments so they
know I sent you that would be much
appreciated after the 27th it's back to
10% off with code MP so if you are
considering getting an air purifier now
is definitely the time links in the
comments enjoy the rest of this episode
I would say that anger is is
important um this is going to be
controversial for people but
there is a reality to a certain extent
in which people have to learn to have a
certain amount of healthy fear of their
Authority right in the sense
that if a police officer comes to arrest
you you have to know that you cannot
resist arrest like you have to know that
you have to be polite and you have to
follow along with what the authority
tells you this is something that you
learn when you're very young so I think
that with children children one of the
things you can do for example is to
reserve
anger for very rare things because of
course the problem that you have is that
if you if you get angry all the time
that at some point it's just noise and
you see that like you you've seen
parents are just always screaming at
their kids and basically the kids have
just like they've learned to tune it out
and they just don't care and they just
don't listen anymore and so I think that
you know if you are usually very calm
and very you know uh just very peaceful
with your kids and try to explain things
and to do things I think that once in a
while if they really step out of bounds
if you raise the your voice if you just
show that it's that you're that you're
angry then the effect of it will will be
will be very strong and the kid will you
know because they know that this is not
a normal thing and if it happens it
means something really serious has
happened yeah no I think that's the
right approach I've usually I think I've
usually reserved those situations for
like you're about to do something that's
going to harm you
that that's usually a thing like playing
with a mirror that's going to fall on
them yeah or like or like you know a
child running into the street and and
you see the car coming it's like that's
a moment to scream and to like pick take
your child shake them a little bit and
be like don't do not like this is you
cannot do this like you have to be
scared of that of this moment I have to
scare you into not killing yourself
basically yeah yeah I think that's right
okay so originally I invited you on
because you put out
Snow White which is so cool so can you
talk about why why did you decide to
rewrite a fairy tale reillustrated it
and put out this beautiful book well you
know I love fairy tales I've love fairy
tales forever you know since I was a kid
and then I rediscovered the fairy tales
when I was reading the fairy tales to my
children and what I would do is I read
them and then at some point I memorize
them and then I would kind of tell them
tell them the fairy tales and try to
find ways to tell them that were
interesting for them and several years
ago when my kids were homeschooling I
wrote a virgin of Snow White as a little
play that the kids were going to put on
and I really enjoyed it and I also found
I had some insights about the story
about some of the things that are a
little mysterious in the uh in the
narrative and so I that just kind of
stayed on the shelf for a while and then
recently when I saw to what extent you
know sadly Disney was just dropping
these fairy tales like just basically
dropping them they were like we don't
want these we you know we actually don't
like them anymore and so I thought okay
this is great because these stories are
you know they don't own them the The
Original Stories obviously they have
their version but they don't own them
they're amazing they're beautiful
they're powerful and you know at some
point there's a saturation of cynicism
you could say right and so one of the
things that's happened is if you think
of Shrek for example where they take
these fairy tale mashups and they turn
them on their head and they're very
cynical about them and they make you
know they have like the kids watch them
but there's also all these like dirty
jokes in them for adults and stuff so
this like real cynical take on Fair
Tales um so all of that runs out at some
point because at some point you even
forget why you cared about the story in
the first place like why are you even
cynical about it after 10 years of
making weird versions and you know
versions where the the the the you know
Snow White is this or that strange in in
you know uh incarnation of of her and so
and so I knew that Disney was going to
make a version of Snow White for the
100th anniversary I'd kind of heard that
to the grap vines that was like more
than two years ago and I thought this
would be a great time to do this like to
just pick it up and to tell a beautiful
insightful celebratory version of the
story and so so I kind of put my I put
my nose to that about two years ago so I
working hard on it and found an amazing
illustrator and uh and I think we did a
I think I'm really proud of what we did
did I think we did a a great job of make
telling the story in a way that's for
kids but also that will provide kind of
insight for adults that's to why it is
that they love this story when they were
kids like what what is it that grabbed
their attention um so that's it and but
it's also it's also going to be a book
in a series so we're doing eight fairy
tales so I'm going to take kind of the
classic fairy tales we're going to
reillustrated them and create like a
also a narrative Arc that runs through
all the books where like the characters
will reappear and patterns will reappear
and there'll be like this kind of
Symphony of fairy tales I guess you
could call it so that's what I'm that
I'm we're already working on the second
and third book now so that is so cool uh
when I was in high school we had to I
don't know for English I guess we had to
bring in a piece of written work to read
to the class and I was going through
Grims fairy tales and I'd never read
Grims Fair fairy tales till high school
and for anyone who hasn't read the real
like Grims fairy tales they are gnarly
they're Grim that's why we even have the
word grim yeah they're it's insane like
what actually happens in um which one is
it Cinderella just all of them they're
yeah they're like gory they're intense
and so I remember reading I think I read
the entire class for the entire class
one of these random fairy tales i' had
found because it was just like there's a
lot going on here so did you take the
original fairy tales as opposed to kind
of the versions Disney put out which are
a lot nicer than the original ones well
so yeah so what of the things that
happened with fairy tales I would say it
h started in the 19th century with kind
of Puritan a kind of Puritan approach to
fairy tales is that people tried to AC
septicide these fairy tales you know in
some ways these were old stories that
have been you know that people have been
telling for centuries like some old
grandmother telling these kind of these
edgy stories you know you can just
imagine the situation yeah you know and
so so what happened in the in the 19th
century especially is that they kind of
accepti them removed a lot of the
extremes and made them into like simple
morality Tales uh but the reality is
that they're more than that there's
actually very deep patterns like there
deep patterns in fairy tales are the
closest thing I would say we have to
something like the patterns in scripture
right they're not the same they're not
equal to but in terms of how much
reality they they contain they're very
similar to what you would find in the
Old Testament for example and so what I
wanted to do is recapture as much as
possible of the old fairy tale without
going overboard like without shocking
people to the extent that now they can't
pay attention to the store anymore
because they're too shocked at like you
know some one of the characters getting
their eyes plucked out you know by a
bird or something like some some of the
crazy stuff you know at the end of Snow
White in the GM virgin they they make
these iron shoes that they heat up and
they put them on the the queen so that
she dances for the wedding it's like
it's just like insane like these crazy
you know endings at there's a lot of
like really intense stuff so I thought
you know let's bring back as much as we
can in the story so a good example is
there's obviously in fairy tales there's
obviously references to uh to sexuality
into sexual transformation especially
the ones that deal with young girls like
a lot of this has to do with puberty
like you can see see it has to do with
with you know like Snow White reaches
puberty she doesn't know what it means
she doesn't know what's going on all of
a sudden her stepmother hates her this
this man is is Hunter is after her like
what the hell's going on you know and
she gets thrown into a loop where she
has to kind of assimilate this new world
that she's thrown into so you know
that's something that's really there and
the the modern fairy tale the Puritan
version tried to strip that out and a
lot of the the cynical postmodernists
tried to sell tried to put it back in
but like way you know at a higher level
and tried to say well these are only
about sex these are only about about
power dynamics and about cynical you
know uh kind of social dynamics and
stuff and so what I wanted to do is to
actually integrate it as much as
possible to say there these stories do
deal with this subject but it's not all
they deal with they deal with all kinds
of other things you know like beauty is
not just about sex so the story of you
know Beauty does have something to do
with sexuality but Snow White obviously
her beauty has other things going on
that is not cannot be reduced to that so
trying to kind of integrate all these
patterns back into the story in a way
that won't shock the reader but
hopefully at least for the grown-ups
they'll be like oh that's why like oh
that's why this is part of the story
right that's why she eats the Apple
that's why these things happen uh and so
that's the that's the the goal let's say
that's cool I'm I'm looking forward to
these that's that's really fun well
you're in the right place too like
you've got you know your daughter is
like just at the age where this is going
to be fun for her to to discover these
so I'm I can't wait to hear what you
think I know I well I wanted to read her
I've been like waiting for the Grims
versions but I remember the Grims
version Rumple stiltskin he gets so
angry at the end he St you probably know
this he stamps his foot through the
floorboards and cuts himself in half I I
remember reading that in high school and
being like okay well I haven't heard
that part of the story or um was
Cinderella's stepsisters they cut off
parts of their feet they cut off their
toes yeah I might keep that part in the
story actually yeah like one does the
heel and one does the toes oh I might
keep that part in the story because of
because especially because of the recent
excess of of plastic surgery you know
it's like it's a it's a big thing in the
culture and so I want to be care I want
people to be able to understand the
dangers of it you know like if you if
you if you cut piece even not just even
in terms of you know in terms of cutting
things off you in order to fit a certain
mold let's say uh you know you see that
with the masectomy and all these kind of
crazy things that are happening to young
teenage girls right now so I think
having the the the the steps that cut
their toes off will be important I'll
have to find a way to do it so that it's
not gory and and crazy but I think these
things are important you know so like
there's a lot of these fairy tales
there's a lot of things they can
communicate to us for example in Snow
White you know the magic mirror there
are some versions where she has the
magic mirror in her hand and that the
illustrator that's working with me
Heather pollington she's like we should
use that version that she hold it in her
hand and she made an illustration of it
and it's like she's holding a phone
right she's just looking at herself and
and she's taking a selfie you know know
and we're like yeah that's exactly it
and so the phone that the mirror is
speaking to her and he's comparing her
to others and is telling her who's the
most beautiful and is pointing out her
faults and her beauty and it's like yeah
that's right that's the right time to
bring up these kind of these kind of
story tropes oh that's creepy yeah well
so are you putting a modern spin on
these then well so you could say that it
yeah it's there I'm careful not to be
like we say these things I don't explain
any of this in the story it's not like I
don't I don't I don't want it to be
dactic it's not uh but I would say that
the the the way that we make certain
elements of the story more prominent uh
that's the way we do it so it's like you
know making the mirror prominent making
these moments where she looks at herself
and she kind of gets feedback from it
and she becomes obsessed at some point
in my version where she's she actually
she can't stop herself from looking in
the mirror and constantly asking it if
it's and as she's doing that she's kind
of destroying
you know she's making her she's
destroying herself because of her
jealousy towards Snow White and so it's
like I'm hoping that people even if it's
not conscious will kind of gather
they'll be able to gather those those
insights into themselves and children
will see the pattern of behavior even if
even though I never say that it's like a
phone or it's I would never do so like
that would be horrible in a fairy tale
it would just be so dactic the best
versions of those fairy tales other than
the Grims versions which are just
horrifying are the Disney the old Disney
versions from like what is it the 30s
until the Disney movie was amazing '90s
yeah yeah those are amazing the Disney
Snow White it's it's not just it's weird
because the Disney story of Snow White
it's really the beginning of a whole era
because people don't realize that it's
the very first long form animated movie
ever made is Disney Snow White people
didn't believe that it was possible
people were like you can't make an you
can't make an hour and a half animation
right animation should be 10 minutes or
should be these little Clips but Disney
really took it on and made this amazing
and invented all these Technologies all
these new ways of animating in order to
to to develop this movie um and so and
and and and people were just amazed at
it and it started a whole like an entire
Century where basically Disney held
children's attention and kind of ruled
over children's attention and for a
while they were good steward of that
attention because the stories they put
out were very powerful and beautiful and
they also had that balance you know that
that your father or that I talk about
that should be in a in a kind of
mythical story where you have everything
is there and kind of balanced out but
then you know they like all of a lot of
the entertainment industry they become
captured by ideology and ideology makes
for boring stories so it's a it's
actually and the same happening in books
too I mean you have a child you know
that you go into a bookstore to buy
books for kids and it's just unbearable
like it's crap it's just bad quality bad
writing IDE ideology everywhere you know
it's like you you you have to you always
have to kind of look twice at what your
kid is reading because you you know it's
so incipit there's people just trying to
get into your child's mind in order to
in order to convert them to their cause
that you have to be attentive to that
and so in some ways that's a horrible
place that a lot of parents find
themselves in but it's also an
opportunity for people who want to tell
good stories because in a mo in a in a
moment of really bad horrible boring
ideological stories then good stories
should should shine brighter and so I
would say encourage people to in it's
okay to criticize I do it all the time
but not just criticize but hopefully you
know take on the mantle yourself you
know learn the stories tell them to your
kids encourage people that are doing it
uh and I think that we could I think
that we we're going to win in the end
because there's a reality to these
stories that is objective that there's a
reason Reon why we care for them there's
reason why we why we love them for
centuries is because they have something
mysterious in them that is true to human
attention that has that is true to what
people care about even if we don't
understand what that is you know it's
still there because we've been telling
these stories for centuries so if you
try to go away from that to just push
your ideological ideas then people will
just stop carrying they'll just find it
boring and that's what's
happening isn't it crazy how much much
JK rolling has been gone after in the
last like four years isn't it insane for
a book that everybody who's going after
red and loves 15 and
loves it's it's like that really shocks
me even like the response TW and
Twitter's well X now is such a weird and
could be toxic plat platform but it just
shocks me the response to JK Rowling who
wrote these stories that are
unbelievable yeah about it's interesting
like this is this is what happens like
even with the this is what H like this
is what happened with Snow White and
this is what happened with Harry Potter
is that these stories have in them true
patterns of human existence and those
patterns have certain structures certain
categories that just play themselves out
and if you catch them right then people
love those stories that's why people
love Star Wars that's why people love
these these these stories um but those
are real like they really do exist and
so the weird position people find
themselves in
is loving Harry Potter because it
basically captures the patterns of human
attention but then at the same time
hating Harry Potter because they're
caught up in their ideological thing and
what they want is that they hope is that
they could twist Harry Potter to their
will like they could make Harry Potter
into something that would fit their IDE
ideology and obviously they're trying to
do that with the author first it's like
if we can just if we can just shame the
author into believing the things we
believe and going along with what we
think is true you know then then we'll
win and we'll have Harry Potter on our
side but the problem is that the problem
is that the Harry Potter that would come
out of that you would hate it you would
find it boring you would find it
annoying because it would just be prop
propaganda and so it's like this weird
moment that it's the J rolling thing is
a great example of how insane and
contradictory this is you know because
it's like you love Star Wars and then
you're like oh this is so cool we're g
to take it over and we're gonna we're
gonna just make it fit in this beautiful
political thing and then why does
everybody hate the movies why is it that
these things are all failing you know
that's how it is it's just yeah just
funny it it is funny um how do you feel
so my husband grew up in a very
Christian household and his family is
really like a really good they're all
really good people which I and I feel
like I didn't meet very many really good
people weirdly enough I guess I don't
know if they're not very common or
something I don't know what was going on
or the schools I was at or something so
I was like surprised at how good they
were but he didn't watch Harry Potter
growing up um because there was this and
I remember hearing about this when I was
in grade two where it was like there's a
subset of people that think Harry Potter
is evil yeah like and mostly like
Christian people that think you know
it's witchcraft and that's evil um what
are your views on that and how do you
well I know what my views are on that I
probably know what your views are on
that but like how how come that got
confused into oh that's evil instead of
looking at the overarching theme of like
good versus evil that's in Harry Potter
okay
so Christians don't like Witchcraft and
don't like magic you know uh but those
same Christians with they'll read Lord
of the Rings and they'll love Lord of
the Rings right and so those same
Christians will read CS Lewis and the
love CS Lewis but in those books like in
Lord of the Rings basically Lord of the
Rings is the template for all for all
fantasy fiction that we that we have and
so the idea of sorcerers and all this
kind of stuff that that uh token was
able to bring together crystallized a
kind of
medieval mythology you could say of
Merlin and all of these kind of
characters that existed in the west into
uh you know into modern narrative and
that became the the the background and
the Trope for everything that came
afterwards including Harry Potter and so
it's like you like you like gandal but
you hate Dumbledore it's like I
understand so and so but I think it's
it's so you could say that in
in in Lord of the Rings the magic is
meant to serve a higher purpose right
it's like the things we do this power
that we have it's meant to serve higher
and higher purposes and the problem with
kind of modern magic or or occultist
magic is that magic is meant to serve
your will and I think that this is in
some ways the problem that people face
when they look at Harry Potter it's like
magic is just like a techn bunch of
technical things it's just like an
increase in power and it's not clear
whether or not it is meant to serve a
higher good it's just like here is a
power you have you can develop it and
you can kind of develop all the
technical skills around it so I think
think that that's that's what's hiding
behind that but on the surface it's just
like you know witchcraft is is devil
worship and they they relate the occult
to to you know to to kind of Satanism or
witchcraft the way that it was
represented in the uh in in you know
16th 17th century in Europe so I I
understand people's aversion to to Harry
Potter like I get it it's but I I think
that it's a little simple let's say you
know I I still think that in general
they're good stories
okay how do you feel about Halloween
then the and the aversion that's this is
really I think Halloween's a good
example of what you could call a Puritan
Spirit taken too far which is this is
the same type of attitude that took all
the weird stuff out of the fairy tales
which is this idea that everything has
to have this kind of
transparent Purity to it and everything
has to be you know objectively how can I
say this like OB objectively
always uh like like I could just say
that transparently pure right but the
reality is that the world doesn't
doesn't doesn't work that way you know
it's like it just it just doesn't it's
the world is more complicated and more
messy than you think and uh you know for
carnivals and festivals of inversion are
everywhere and in every culture what's
what's a festival Festival of inversion
yeah an upside down Festival right so a
carnival is something like that so think
about about uh you know during a
carnival you do things that you usually
don't do you dress up you wear masks you
you know you you usually there's
acrobatics involved people spinning and
turning upside down and making jokes and
and uh and pulling tricks and doing all
these things that are not
straightforward it's like you know you
have things that are straightforward and
directed towards purpose and identity
and then you also have a kind of
messiness and and inversion and upside
down behavior that you can notice on the
edge
and that's what carnivals of inversions
are and every culture has them so
usually like before a fast you know if
you before uh before lent for Christians
they would have something called Migra
which you've probably seen mardig gr
parades you know obviously now they've
become crazy but they've always been a
little bit like that they've always been
a little you know a little off color you
know lwd maybe a little there's a bit of
uh you know there's crossdressing and
and uh and funny things that don't make
sense you know people on stilts or you
know all this kind of aesthetic you
could call it an aesthetic of chaos or
an aesthetic of of
inversion uh and that serves a function
in a society right so basically you have
order right you have the ordered world
that everything is ordered and
purposeful and moving towards what it's
supposed to be but then you you you know
that those things exist but you know
that there are messy chaotic things and
there are monsters and there are there
are places where things don't fit and
inversions and excesses and all like you
know and so Carnival festivals basically
take them out to play for one day and
then put them back right and what that
does is it acts like a valve first of
all to let some of that stuff out
because it builds up after a while and
it also acts as a reminder of what's
normal right it's like a counter example
it's saying this is
Carnival all right let's have fun now
for a day and let's be little wild and
now let's go back to normal so it's like
oh that's what normal is and that's what
not normal is so you kind of you kind of
understand how that works and and
Halloween that's what Halloween is I
mean Halloween is basically you know the
A Day of the Dead where the dead walk
the earth which is something that
doesn't happen which is some it means
that all the all the the the broken kind
of monstrous chaotic you know funny
slightly sexy slightly you know like all
the things that we don't usually put
outside in the world now all of a sudden
they come out and we see them and we're
like wow this is crazy this is wild it's
kind of like going to to a a county fair
and going on you know and looking all
the bright lights and all the the people
dressed up and the clowns and all that
so that's what's going on and then it's
like all right one day and then we go
back to to normal and so you know this
by the way in the Bible there's a feast
called Purim which is there it's a it's
a it's a Jewish feast and Jews still
celebrate it today where one day year
they dress up and and costumes and do
all this kind of wild stuff and you know
they spin around and they drink and they
dance and they do all these things but
it's just it's just one day so so and
that's something go has that some is
that something God's put in place for
people that's what purum purum is that
exactly and that's what Marty so
obviously you don't you have to be
careful on those days you know because
you could do something to compromise
yourself and that you want to be careful
like in some ways it can also expose you
it can expose your vices if you're not
careful uh and so the idea is to
basically kind of get a bit of wild out
so you can see it so you can kind of
handle it in a way that's not completely
immoral or completely dangerous and then
put it back and then move on uh because
if you don't do that what happens is at
some point it breaks out and then it
takes
over right if you don't know what the
monsters look like and you don't
understand what the chaos looks like at
some point it just it just basically
sweeps in I think a lot of yeah that
that I didn't know what part of the
Bible is that in do you remember so the
the feast ofurum is established it's
complicated it's established in the Book
of Esther oh the Book of Esther is a is
so the Book of Esther is basically like
a kind of almost like a lurgical text
for purm and so you know in the in the I
don't know exactly what date the Feast
of purum was established but it's you
know Jews Like I said Jews still
celebrate purum today most Christians
don't though most Christians have
something like marig gr or they've had
in the past they've had something like
the Feast of fools uh and then Hallow's
Eve right and so so if you want to look
at how Halloween functions what it
actually is it's actually a Catholic
it's the eve of All Hallows right that's
what Halloween means and so what it was
in the past is that All Hallows was the
day that you celebrated that you prayed
for the dead right and then after that
was all Saints which is the day that you
celebrated all those that have passed
that are now in God's presence and so
it's and so then what ended up being
developed was before All Hallows there
was like a little Carnival in some ways
in which the more chaotic aspects of
death and the more kind of you know wild
aspects of what death brings and the
strange and the weird and the trick and
all of these things that that kind of
break down order so that we can move
towards something like a celebration of
the holy Saint that have that have gone
to to God so that was the usual Order of
Things sadly now we just have Halloween
but we can still understand its function
if you can see how it lines up with
those other feasts and how it was like a
kind of procession towards something
glorious not just not just a feast of
the upside down I mean now the problem
is that we basically live in Halloween
all the time it's like our world is a
carnival that's why people say it's
clown world is because the carnival has
basically taken over yeah I I I feel
like I I feel like a lot of people who
aren't Christians are probably put off
by the idea of Christianity thinking
that oh if if the goal is to never
sin then I won't be able to do anything
fun ever I like I can see that from an
agnostic perspective like a simple
perspective but I don't think they
understand
that like even factions of Christianity
to the that say don't drink ever cuz
drinking is bad or don't use electricity
or you know who knows like what what
direction people can go in but that's
not what I got out of the Bible anyway
no I don't think so I I don't know how
it's like what you were talking about
Puritans it really is the idea
that the joys we have and the pleasures
we have should always be aligned towards
higher goods and if we're not careful
about that then we we then we kind of
fall into these cycles of addiction and
these cycles of of obsession and so you
know the idea that
that in some way and and you know it
depends how strict the different
Traditions are but in some way sexuality
has to be aimed towards something higher
and so right you you meet someone you
know and then there's all the pleasure
is there and the joy is there but it's
also towards a purpose of forming a bond
forming communion bringing a child into
the world becoming a family seeing that
beautiful relationship that develops and
being a little kind of microcosm of
everything like being a little a little
society that you that you live in that's
that's the highest that's moving towards
highest and so it's like there's nothing
wrong with with with with sex and
enjoying that as long as it's it's kind
of anchored in something more if it's
just for itself then you have hookup
culture and despair and and people who
just kind of move from one partner to
the other and then finally you know uh
you know basically ruin their their
lives and end up alone and lonely in
their in their 40s or whatever uh and I
think and and so it's that's just an
example but truth of everything right
it's like the joys that we have it's
it's a weird Paradox but the idea is
that whatever Joy you have if you are
willing to in some ways submit it to
something higher sacrifice it for
something higher then you get it in its
fullness right it's like a a meal with
friends in which you're enjoying each
other's presence will be more
pleasurable right than than the best
food you could have that youve you know
you got up at 1: in the morning out of
an insane craving and you're like just
eating the best food in in quotation
marks that will not provide you with a
higher Joy but if you do it if you're
with friends and it's like this thing
that that's kind of participating in
higher Goods then you'll get the most of
it and that's the Paradox of pleasure
you could
say what are your views on the like red
pill Bros push towards polygamy like I
never I didn't even hear what polygamy
was until I was like 15 like I didn't
even know people thought like that
anymore but I wasn't aware of like
different cultures around the world I
was much more na the idea of having
several wives yeah why is this have you
have you heard this it's in the red pill
community that they're like I'm sure it
exists I'm not I wouldn't be I'm not
surprised that he would exist these guys
are all going to become Muslim like
they're just moving towards Islam uh you
know Christianity Christianity is is has
been from the beginning a monogamous uh
a monogamous thing and and it's it's
there in the words of Christ that
ultimately the joining of a duality
right the joining of two opposites
together that is the highest image of
what let's say of the Union of the
person with God and so the marriage as
two people coming together and becoming
one that becomes an image of our
relationship with God and so you know
the the the the idea of polygamy you
know let's say reduces the
relationship of uh let's say reduces the
relationship between men and women as
something like a master and servants
ultimately is what that that does and I
think that that is at least in the
Christian Vision that is not what we're
called to right it's like we're actually
called God is our Master but God is also
seen as our lover as seen as the one
that wants to bring our life into his so
that we can participate fully in his joy
in his love and and that's why
Christianity is monogamous because
because it's not just a submit to the
higher principle thing although it's
part of it but it's not just that it
really is this this kind of dance where
we move into into a Rel a true
relationship and a true Union with God
that was pretty does that make sense
that in some ways yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it it that's why that's why in
certain that's why in certain Traditions
it's still permissible and it's usually
because that is the way they perceive
reality and that's the way they perceive
God as
well okay that makes sense I just
thought it was funny that it's kind of
permeating into the red pilled Western
culture like I would say most most
people um who have who consider them red
pilled on YouTube what they preach is
polygamy blatantly CU they said that's
that's just the way of men who are very
dominant it's to have 12 wives or to
have and that's just how it's supposed
to be naturally From Evolution that's
what they say yeah well you know and I
think so let's look at it objectively
like let let's let's look at it
objectively the greatest even in terms
of total red pill let me take a red pill
position here for a moment it's like the
empires that have been the most powerful
and have lasted the longest and have had
the most reach you could say let's let's
say Rome for example Rome was mainly Pol
was mainly monogamous in its in its
structure although there was that kind
of practical polygamy where you know
guys would probably sleep around and
stuff but like there was a there was a a
main monogamy in terms of social
structure and then Christianity takes
that even further and then you know
let's
say there's a reason why the West expand
Ed it to become almost a global a global
influence and monogamy is is part of
that because it is
ultimately the best the best Bond and
the best way to to raise children that
will have the strength and the capacity
to to take over from you if there is
that strong that strong bond and that
strong relationship at least that's what
I what I think so I don't think I think
that even in terms of you know the let's
say the the even in terms of the red
pill br that try to look at it just
purely in terms of material causes they
should take into account the reason why
the West developed in this direction and
not think that it's purely accidental
that there are actual reasons why that
happened they probably just put
themselves at the top and they're like
nah I'm the outlier though I can do it
that's the thing that's the thing about
all these guys that's hilarious is that
is like you think that's right but then
then you think you're going to be the
one with the 12 wives or you're just
going to be the Unix he's castrated and
is protecting the herum it's like that's
not a you know it's not it's not a great
uh you know it's just funny that people
always think that they're going to be at
the top when like you see that in a lot
of people that are kind of that have a
tendency towards
monarchism uh you know sometimes you
talk to them and you realize it's
because oh you think you're going to be
the king that's why you're that's why
you have that position that's funny yes
that's exactly it though that's
definitely it oh that's good okay well
Jonathan it was nice talking to you I'm
really excited about your books I think
they'll be so good for people I'm
definitely getting them all oh thanks I
okay yeah I can't wait to hear what you
think when you get them that'll be
that'll be that'll be wonderful like
where's the gore
no just kidding no I'm sure they'll be
good it'll be good if I can read them to
scarlet and their AR there's not too
much Gore there's a little bit of Gore
okay good not a lot just to keep things
spicy just there's there is blood you
can't have snow white without a of blood
oh wow okay that sounds good well thank
you again for coming on thank you thanks
for having me
[Music]
on